Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our head and neck anatomy series.
In this video, we're going to be talking about the muscles of mastication.
So the muscles of mastication are muscles involved with moving the mandible, providing
the ability to chew or masticate.
They're formed from the paraxial mesoderm of the first pharyngeal arch.
This is that mesodermal tissue that develops on either side of the neural tube in the embryo.
As we talked about in our second video, it's also responsible for forming the posterior
skull.
Since it's coming from the first pharyngeal arch, it's no surprise that these muscles
are being innervated by the trigeminal nerve, cranial nerve 5, specifically the third division
of cranial nerve 5.
All of the muscles of mastication originate from the skull in a place other than the
mandible, and they insert into the mandible to allow it to move.
So we'll go from outside to inside and start with the masseter muscle.
Now for every muscle that we review, in this video and in the videos to come, we'll recite
the origin, insertion and action for every muscle.
Intervation is the other high yield thing to know for every muscle, but I'll usually
point that out at the beginning of a muscle group, and oftentimes each muscle in that
group is innervated by the same nerve, which makes things a whole lot easier to remember.
So the masseter is actually broken into two distinct parts, a superficial part that we
can clearly see, and a deep part that's peeking out behind the superficial part.
So the superficial part has oblique or diagonally running fibers, and they originate at the anterior
two thirds of the zygomatic arch, and insert into the lateral surface of the ramus down
to the angle.
The deep part has vertical running fibers, it also originates from the zygomatic arch
but a bit more posteriorly, and it also inserts into the lateral surface of the ramus as well
as the angle.
I always think of a muscle like a rope, and the origin is where a person who is standing
still is pulling the rope towards them, and the insertion is whatever on the other end
of the rope getting pulled toward that person.
So the origin is immobile, and the insertion is mobile, and the muscle is what's controlling
that movement.
So what is the masseter's action or function?
Well, it elevates or closes the mandible, and this makes perfect sense because the primary
direction of those fibers is running up towards the zygomatic arch, pulling the insertion toward
the origin.
Secondarily, the superficial fibers can actually protrude the mandible forward, while the deep
fibers can retract or retrude the mandible after it's been protruded.
Again, this makes sense just looking at the orientation of those muscle fibers.
Lastly, if a masseter muscle is activated, only on one side, it can move the mandible
toward that side, so if the left masseter activates, it can move the mandible to the
left.
I'm going to show you something a little bit later towards the end of the video to help
you remember this.
Another way to say this is that unilateral action produces ipsilateral excursion.
That's a lateral movement toward the same side.
So if we cut away the masseter and the zygomatic arch, we see the full temporalis muscle.
The temporalis muscle originates in the temporal fossa, which we spent a whole lot of time talking
about in our fossa video, specifically along the temporal line.
It inserts into the coronoid process of the mandible, and it functions to elevate or close
the mandible, which again makes sense.
If we just look at the orientation of those fibers, the pull is going to be parallel to
those fibers.
Again, the origin is located above the insertion point, so it will pull up on the mandible
at its coronoid process.
Secondarily, the posterior fibers, which run a bit more obliquely, can retrude or retract
the mandible back.
If we cut away the ramus and go even further in toward the infratemporal fossa area, we
see the medial pterogoid muscle down here.
This one also has a superficial and a deep part, just like the masseter did.
The superficial part here originates at the tuberosity of the maxilla, and also the pyramidal
process of the palatine bone.
The deep part originates from the medial surface of the lateral pterogoid plate, and this is
how it gets its name, not from it being the lateral pterogoid plate, but that it's originating
from the medial surface of the lateral pterogoid plate.
It inserts into the medial or internal surface of the ramus down to the angle, basically
on the opposite side that the masseter attaches to it.
It elevates the mandible and provides some protrusion.
Again, just look at the direction of the pull of the muscle fibers.
Now, if a medial pterogoid muscle is activated only on one side, it moves the mandible toward
the opposite side.
So if this left medial pterogoid is activated, the mandible will move to the right.
In other words, unilateral action produces contralateral excursion.
Last but not least, we have the lateral pterogoid muscle.
And this one has a superior and inferior head.
The superior head originates at the infrared temporal crest, and that's the superior border
of the infrared temporal fossa, and it inserts into the articular disc and joint capsule
of the temporal mandibular joint.
The inferior head originates lower down at the lateral surface of the lateral pterogoid
plate, hence the name lateral pterogoid muscle, and it inserts into the condylar neck at
a depression known as the pterogoid fovea.
Now both superior and inferior head work together to pull the disc and the condyle forward and
down the articular eminence, and this initiates jaw opening and protrudes the mandible.
As with the medial pterogoid muscle, unilateral action produces contralateral excursion.
Now I'm bringing back this image that I showed you in the last video on facial spaces because
honestly this gets really cool.
So this is a cross-section view, technically from the front of the skull looking at the
right side of the head.
We have the zygomatic arch out here, the mandible, with the coronoid process cut through and
the condyle sitting behind it.
We have the temporal bone appear, the infra temporal crest over here, and the lateral pterogoid
plate right here.
Now all four muscles that we just talked about with all of their origins and insertions
are shown in this image on the left.
And those muscles make up those four masticator spaces we discussed in the last video.
And then I showed you this simplified drawing to make a diamond to help you remember how
all those muscles are positioned, and all those bones are positioned to make up those
four quadrants.
But we can also use this drawing for another purpose.
So all we have to do is highlight the mandible.
And I told you before, I have a really easy way to remember the excursion direction of
each of these muscles.
So check this out, the temporalis is going to pull on that mandible straight up.
So there's no excursion there.
The masseter pulls on the mandible outward.
So it's going to pull the mandible toward that same side.
Both pterogoid muscles pull in on the mandible.
So they're going to want to pull it toward the opposite side.
Now you can also see how the temporalis, the masseter, and the medial pterogoid all pull
up on the mandible, effectively closing it, while the lateral pterogoid pulls the mandible
straight so it moves forward, and as a result of that, we'll also move down along the natural
slope of the articular eminence.
So that's pretty darn cool.
So that's it for this video guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it, and subscribe to this channel for more on dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do here, please check out my Patreon
page, thank you to all of my patrons here for their support.
You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on, and practice questions
for the board exams.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone, and I'll see you in the next video.